I don't know how many of you saw the  bizarre Newsmax interview where  right-wing actor and the father of  actress Angelina Jolie John Voight  interviews the failed former president  Donald Trump and Voigt cries during the  interview I'm just very grateful for  your presence in so many areas but uh  yeah first of all I think it's so nice  the way you express that and even the  slight little tears that come you're  just a fantastic person now he is an  actor is it real or not I don't really  know  it is a level of sucking up and  brown-nosing that I have not seen before  the Jon Voight interview  would make those North Korean news  anchors blush and say this is too  propagandistic if you haven't seen the  interview you've got to check it out